Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday!
I was gonna make a thoughts from places video from Dublin,
but then I realized that you took all of my footage
and used it in your Dublin video,
so I'm left with just this clip of a woman smelling her pitted shame
like she is an opponent of the Swintown Swoodilipopers.
Who, by the way, Hank, have three games left
in their entire FIFA '11 history and are on the cusp of winning the Barclay's Premier League.
Link in the doobly-doo.
So Hank, I was pretty upset with you for borrowing all of my footage from Dublin,
But then something much more important happened.
I began to develop a cold sore.
You can't really see it, but you know how you know you're gonna get one before you get one,
yeah, I know I'm gonna get one.
So, Hank, why is that such a big deal?
Well, on Thursday, I'm gonna be in a Google Plus Hangout with
the President of the United States, Barack Obama,
and I am probably going to have a cold sore.
My only hope of not having a cold sore is this stuff,
Abreva, which is the only FDA approved medication for cold sores,
and literally costs more than gold.
Wait, did you just say I was going to be in a Google Plus Hangout
with the president of the United States of America?
[Makes a siren sound]
Is the sound that my anxiety makes.
Hank, I have no idea why this happened,
but someone at Google called me a couple of days ago
and was like, "Do you want to hang out with the President?"
And I was like, "Neee, it depends.
The president of what?"
Because I just hung out with the president of DFTBA Records,
Hank Green, for like a week and a half,
and he was like alright, but you know, I wouldn't do it again.
And they were like, "Yeah, the President of the United States,
Barack Obama. Do you want to be in a Google Hangout and ask him a few questions?"
And I was like, "Mmm...okay.
So, Hank, I am gonna get to ask the President some questions.
I'm gonna improvise a bit, but I have prepared a few.
My first question is, "H-hi Mr. President, my name is John Green,
OH MY GOD WHAT IS AIR?!"
Then I also have, "Would you rather fight ten duck-size horses
or one horse-size duck?"
And of course, "Mr. President, I can't help but notice that Canada got rid of its one cent coin,
and nothing bad happened. HOW DO WE STILL LIVE IN A WORLD WITH PENNIES?!"
And of course, I have to ask him who the eff is Hank.
By the way, Hank, you can also ask questions to the President, as can anyone.
There's a link in the doobly-doo to submit your questions.
There is also a link in the doobly-doo to RSVP to the Hangout, or whatever,
I don't understand this terminology.
But basically, it will be live on YouTube at 4:50 PM Eastern Time on Thursday,
I would be the one with the cold sore.
Anyway, Hank, I'm intellectually aware of the fact the President of the United States doesn't care if I have a cold sore,
and also, that he will forget who I am,
within like 4 seconds at the end of the Google Hangout,
so that he can go back to like...country running.
But I am none the less extremelly anxious of the cold sore,
and also every other facet of this interaction.
And I saw a similar phenomenon, albiet on a much different scale, when we were on tour,
because many people, when we met them, were very, like, nervous and self-conscious.
Hank, we met more than 6,000 Nerdfighters in ten days,
and I can say with authority that NONE of them had anything to be embarrassed about.
But I know that many of them still felt embarrassed anyway.
I also felt embarrassed.
And that's kinda the inherent problem with meeting people you admire or whose work you really like,
it will never be 'normal' because you're always going to be hyper-conscious of everything that could go wrong.
And if, say, you're President of the United States, you have those interactions with people EVERY SINGLE DAY, Hank.
Like, most of your interactions, even with your staff or with people who are like,
"Oh my God, that's the President, everybody be calm."
THAT is the number one reason why I would never wanna be President.
The number two reason is that no matter how sensible your policy idea is,
people only want to talk about ideology.
And the number three reason is that I get cold sores every winter, and if you're President,
you can't hide.
Hank, when the Yeti and I started dating, she told me that when she was in 8th grade,
she realized that everyone else was thinking about themselves as much as she was thinking about herself,
and that therefore, no one else had any time to think about her.
This epiphany was one of the central reasons why Sarah was a relatively well-adjusted teenager.
She realized that when she was like, thirteen,
I realized it when I...I'm actually still trying to internalize it.
Hopefully it will happen before Thursday afternoon.
But regardless Hank, I'll see you on Friday.